[Music]
it was the promise to implement sweeping
reforms reforms that would challenge
Thailand's powerful institutions like
its military and monarchy that let them
move forward party to electoral Victory
the party led by Peter Lim jaronrat
formed an alliance with seven other
parties including patai the second
largest winner in the May general
election
their control of the lower house was not
enough to make him prime minister he
needed but failed to get the endorsement
of the military-appointed Senate the
Constitutional court is also
investigating whether Peter broke
election laws which could see him banned
from politics for up to 10 years if
found guilty analysts say the recent
events have put the alliance at risk of
breaking apart in the end bundling the
two together the tying or not will not
be fruitful for the arrangement
especially not only of the eight parties
together but also for the whole
situation together as a package
a new vote for a prime minister is
expected to take place next Thursday in
Parliament Peter has said if he failed
to become Prime Minister he would
support Coalition partner per ties
candidate
because that person will likely be Sita
tawi sin a property Tycoon seen as a
more acceptable choice to conservatives
but seta will face the same hurdles that
Peter did in Parliament many senators
and some elected representatives from
pro-military parties have said they will
not support a prime ministerial
candidate from an alliance that includes
the move forward party they say they
don't agree with its proposal to amend
loss that criminalize criticism of the
monarchy
move forward supporters like democracy
activistsuk say they would be angry if
the party which won the most seats in
Parliament ends up becoming the
opposition supporters are planning to
hold demonstrations in the coming days
there's no other alternative but to
fight to get true democracy this shows
that the normal way of casting votes and
expecting to get the government you want
has now crumbled
for now protests have been relatively
small and peaceful but analysts haven't
ruled out the possibility they can get
much larger depending on what happens in
the days and weeks ahead Florence Louis
Al Jazeera Bangkok